thank you thank you this is on I've been
out there taking cell phone pictures of
all the other speakers incredibly
intimidating space I first of all my
thanks to intelligence squared for
having me I mind it's such a privilege
to be here I feel like um all the great
lecturers have had like these these
great show and tells these these
presentations is you know electrostatic
forces and laughing gas and you know
mechanical displays the universe and I
feel sort of under armed here but I well
I'll do my best to to live up to the the
history here I think it's actually quite
quite pointed and right that you know I
launched this book in in the UK and that
we're speaking here in this room because
you know in a sense the you know the
ability for technology to change the
world really or originates here you know
with the beginnings of mechanization
steam and and you know the you know the
first factories and and all that and
I've been sort of traveling up and down
the country and then looking at now what
were the forces that came together to
create an industrial revolution in the
first place and and how could we redo it
what would it mean today so what I what
I'm gonna walk through with you today is
is is really just done the continuation
of a story you know very well that's
really at least on the on my side than
on the digital side you know is started
with the personal computer and then the
web and then on and I think this is sort
of a third way for the digital
revolution and this one could be the
biggest yet I'm gonna I'm gonna start
with you know the the the topic you know
the the kind of a bold statement a new
industrial revolution I hope by the time
I'm done with the presentation that
you'll you'll you'll engage enough to
think that it might just happen that
this might really live up to that phrase
and this room one slide of the thesis
and then we'll straight go straight into
pictures now this is it this is the sim
simple thesis which is that the last 20
years have been amazing we've lived
through it we have seen what
happens when you give powerful tools to
ordinary people we have seen what the
internet and the personal computer and
the browser and social networking and
blogs and all that do it changes the
world and it changes the world not by
necessarily providing you know creating
more powerful tools but rather giving
them to more people democratizing
technology is the most powerful force
out there because it allows individuals
to do bring their own ideas their own
voices their own contacts their own uses
are their own imagination and that's how
we change the world it's by spreading
technology not just inventing it so that
was the web and that was fantastic but
we live in the real world here we are
we've chosen to come together in this
room because there's something about
physicality that matters more and as
wonderful as what we've done on the
screen has been I think that to take
those social forces as innovation models
you know the the wondrous communities
that we've built on the web and apply
them to something as world-changing as
sort of needle moving as manufacturing
could could dwarf what we've already
done in the digital space on our screens
industrial revolutions are are you know
these are not just economic forces
they're not just industrial the first
Industrial Revolution did more than
create spoons and cutlery and and and
fabrics it improved quality of life it
rich it vastly reduced child mortality
it basically made us healthier and
happier by amplifying human potential it
replaced muscle power with machine power
it replaced our bodies with our brains
and it allowed us to move from what you
may have thought of we may have thought
it was being the pastoral rural rural
you know grounds but was really sort of
you know damp buildings with disease
into the cities and built what we now
known and now know today as the modern
the modern world it did many great
things and created the 20th century in
the 19th century in the 21st century but
it came at a cost and the cost was
concentration of power we moved to the
factories we moved to the machines they
didn't move to us
um there were cottage industries first
but they were largely doing piecework
for the man if you will you know for the
larger factories that to really amplify
power we had to we had to eat we had to
concentrate ourselves around the
industrialists around the sort of the
business models that worked around the
mass and so this sort of you know sort
of you know slave to the Machine
you know model was incredibly efficient
but did come at a cost of diversity of
cultural richness of sort of you know
the individuality of before that it was
a price worth paying for what it did to
prosperity and quality of life but it
was a price um that was the first
Industrial Revolution yeah now there's
actually very little agreement on when
the Industrial Revolution started when
it finished was it the first you know
we've had we had you know you know
spinning wheels back into the medieval
times the spinning jenny sort of had
multiple wheels then there was steam
then there was electrification then
there was the assembly line mass
production interchangeable parts there's
actually in a much debate over that but
let's just argue that there was a sort
of that you know an industrial
revolution it was sort of eighteen it
started sort of 1776 II and kind of went
until like you know the Ford Model T
assembly line and that was you know
manufacturing by and large then you can
argue that the Second Industrial
Revolution was was the computer I mean
the information revolution but rather
than show you a computer I'm actually
going to kind of divide revolution into
two parts the first is this sort of
again democratization is key of what
we're talking about here it is not just
the creation of the tools it is putting
in the hands of regular folks since is
getting them out there is empowering
individuals to change the world so the
first was that was the introduction of
the word sort of desktop as in desktop
publishing as in personal computer it
was and I show you up there that the
first of laser writer the apple
laserwriter which is the first kind of
consumer laser printer cost $2,500 and
came out around the same time as the
Macintosh in 1984
1985 um when you think about it desktop
publishing I mean we now use this word
for you take his word for granted but
but you know think of how mind-blowing
that was some of you may even remember
that desktop publishing never publishing
was a factory act it was that there was
the means of production right before
that printing plants were you know the
size of a city block gots in a bought
ink by the barrel rolls a paper on
railway cars you know to be a newspaper
to publish to influence public opinion
you needed to have access to a factory
and and that was publishing that's what
publishing took and then Along Came the
Macintosh and the laser writer and
Melissa printer and and then anybody
could publish that really professional
quality it was kind of amazing we made
you know dogs breakfast of terrible
pages with mishmash of fonts and you
know completely completely you know did
not did not understand the aesthetics of
you know 300 years of typography but we
learned quickly and and we eventually
kind of you know figured out fonts and
typefaces and kerning and letting and
all that kind of stuff and we got we
figured it out
but that was just making a few we could
prints you know lost cat posters and you
know church Flyers etc but it wasn't
really publishing right publishing his
mass publishing his one-to-many and he
can't do that on a laser printer and
then Along Came the second essential
element which was the democratization of
the tools of the distribution and that
was the web and that's how we changed
the world we we were empowered to
publish you know and to feel that way
that we we could you know sin we could
we could have something to say that was
Amelie and interesting but looked good
and then we were given a vehicle to
transmit it to the world
and that's you know that that that
toppled the monopoly of mainstream media
of which I am one you know I have a you
know I we in the mainstream media
industry had he had he had a fantastic
thing going in the 20th century
you know we had monopolies or or let's
say let's say you do you know poly opsin
II or you know we had we had sort of
collective ownership a small number of
companies where I had access to these
extraordinary to
of distribution their radio and
television and printing plants etcetera
and we lost it and and what happened is
not that we were destroyed it's that we
we saw a new kind of media one that was
not making the same thing we were making
Hollywood films and glossy magazine but
instead it was expressing individual
voices ideas passions creativity the
long tail my first book and that's and
that rich inning of society because we
gave everybody a voice was the true
cultural revolution that came along with
the Industrial Revolution of of giving
publishing to everybody
okay so that was 20 years ago in the
last the last 20 years have been
basically about sort of you know
democratizing digital putting putting
these powerful tools in the hands of
everybody so that they could put pixels
on screens and that's been great but
we've just begun so let's just take
these two these two necessary elements
making one and making many and advance
it to the current day rather than the
laser printer we have the 3d printer um
this is this is my little 3d printer
it's it's laser-cut and crude and I put
it together with you know myself and and
it didn't work for a long time until it
did and and and it was just the
beginning but but the 3d printer I think
is probably as revolutionary a device as
as the first personal computer was a 3d
printer just for those of you who don't
know is is really just like if you think
of what a printer does a regular paper
printer like the one on you having your
desk it serve takes pixels on the screen
and puts them in atoms on paper in this
case a layer of ink a 3d printer takes
shapes on the screen and put some in
layers and builds up an object even
plastics or metals or something else and
it's like the Star Trek replicator where
you just sort of anything you can
imagine you can fabricate and it so
beautifully builds up with this kind of
alien logic of how it you know how it
builds the honeycombs internally it's
kind of it it's kind of Awesome and
mesmerizing and it's still a bit crude
it's kind of like the dot matrix yeah ed
period but you can do it and mine cost
under a thousand dollars and today you
can get really good ones for for around
two thousand dollars and they're
starting to
look like the stuff you could buy and
you can make anything anything you can
imagine you could make okay but that's
one and it's really slow by the way it's
like 20 minutes so cool but not
industrial revolution you need that next
step you need to democratize the tools
of distribution and let me just tell you
about story the right screen there
that's a picture from a website called
Alibaba what I got started in this whole
thing I was kind of messing around my
kids and you know playing around with
Lego Mindstorms robotics and then we got
into Arduino which is the kind of
open-source computing platform and you
can program it to turn on LEDs and move
meat sensors and move motors and things
like that and we decided to be cool to
make a blimp a little sort of autonomous
blimp and blintz by the right lovely
they you know that little sort of
balloons like this and they have little
sensors and motors and and they sleep on
the ceiling I love that you know when
they're done they just sort of hang out
on the ceiling and and they like they're
like whales they just kind of float
around so it was we invented this
autonomous blimp robot clip and then we
kind of blogged about it you said sir
you know it's really simple you just
sort of you just have got to click on
this link and then have this printed
circuit board fabricated and then you
click on these 17 links that you know
this electronics part supply or and get
these parts and then you solder it
together and then you program it and
everyone's like can you just do that for
me please because it sounds really
complicated and so we said okay we'll
make it and got all the parts and you
know Ben baggies and boxes and those
kind of stuff and you know arrange the
children around the dining room table
and gave them all assignments and a
lesson do not put the six-year-old on
quality assurance not only will she do a
terrible job but when the customer is
going to complain and you say well a
six-year-old do it did it I'm so sorry
but you know what expect they're like
why did you put a six year old they're
not they're not sympathetic but in the
course of doing this we we needed motors
for the propellers and and the motors
were really expensive like seven dollars
each for the motors and I was like they
gotta be cheaper so I said me and China
you can buy cheaper motors and I went to
this website Alabama and looking for
cheap motors and instead what they
wanted was
what kind of butter yeah they're like
these like what tell me what kind of
motor you want and I was like I don't
even know what language to use here and
they had these little so it's like it
turns out it's a shaft length the number
of windings and the magnets and the you
know the voltage and and all this kind
of stuff and they had this instant
message application that translates in
real-time between Chinese and English
and I just sort of they kind of walk me
through it and I sort of describe what
kind of motor I want and ten days later
a box of a thousand motor showed up and
I was like oh my god I made robots in
China
what for me and they took paint now now
I only used to live in China you know I
used to I used to spend all my time in
the factories and dongwon and in
Shenzhen and you know literally just ten
years ago if you wanted factories in
China to work for you you had to fly to
Hong Kong you then had to get an
introduction to the factory you had to
go across the border you had to meet
with them there was some awkward sort of
you know exchanges you ventually go to a
restaurant you'd be forced to eat fish
eyeballs you'd drink a lot that beat
some karaoke it was humiliating and only
after this hazing ritual and an
important part of its sort of a bank
transfer you know deal would they allow
you to place an order and I just done it
with like a few clicks on a website in
PayPal and I suddenly realized that that
and that was the moment let it got
chills that was the moment that I sort
of said holy cow this is not just
tinkering in your workshop this is this
is the global supply chain opening up to
everybody this is the web equivalent and
basically what we've just said what we
what I established over the last few
years is the factory in the cloud you
know we've seen what the cloud can do it
gives basically industrial scale
computing to everybody you know every
time you search your gut your Gmail
you're basically getting out you know
kind of a supercomputer worth of
computing just working for you and for
free and we're now doing the same with
manufacturing this what happened
actually I did a little research on this
what happened is that sir three things
happened in China around this time the
first is that a the web generation came
into power and they just got it they
understood that you know working
the seam of the web was the the future
of their businesses second is that
they're their own technologies became
more and more automated so they could
make small batches and bespoke bespoke
orders that was simply a matter of just
changing the programming the commitment
and the robots would then make different
stuff and the third is that they start
to go into this sort of economic
slowdown by which they wanted to kind of
move out of the commodity low-margin
space and do some more small batch
high-value uh orders so although I was
getting an incredible discount they were
getting a premium over the you know
whatever every anybody else's was paying
them so the ability to serve the small
as well as a large turn out to be good
for everybody so that's so that was a
moment when I sort of said I can make
one and I can make many and I suddenly
was in the manufacturing business
without having a little leaving money
Mike my kitchen table there was a matter
of just point and click and then you
start to see the pieces come together
this at this moment and when I realized
that just invented something and then
manufactured it I suddenly flashed back
35 no longer gosh well 37 years to my
summers spent with my grandfather in Los
Angeles this is my grandfather Fred
Houser
he was a Swiss immigrant in Los Angeles
in the 1930s and he worked in Hollywood
he worked in the you know how it was a
very mechanical business in those days
and they had these you know mechanical
film drives and tape loops and things
like that and by day he made the gears
run in those films and by night he
dreamed of inventions and this is him at
his drafting table and this is what he
invented he invented the automatic
sprinkler system so if you have an
automatic sprinkler system you have my
grandfather to thank and my very very
small family fortune came from came from
that interestingly what do you think
back this is exactly what a Swiss
engineer would invent in Los Angeles
it's basically a sprinkler system with a
watch on top of it
there is Destin he was destined to do
this but you know what he had to do was
this he had to patent it he hated this
he hated the cost to hated the the time
and he hated working with lawyers but
the reason he had a patent it is because
the only way an invention could get out
there into the marketplace to change the
world
was through a patenting and licensing
process and what this what this
represents is is a is a necessary but
tragic loss of control what this says is
I'm I'm incapable of manufacturing I
need somebody else to do it and this is
the mechanism by which we transfer the
idea from me the inventor to you the
manufacturer and it came out as the
moody rain master as you can see it
allows you to sunbathe in peace while
your garden stays green and you know
look this is a huge success I mean this
is this is this is a one in a thousand
situation my grandfather was a was eight
was a was a happy man his idea did get
into the marketplace he was well
compensated there's really nothing
nothing tragic about this at all and yet
although I spent my summers with him
this is this is me at I think four or
five learning mechanical drawing with
Grandpa and this is me at 12 learning
learning how to use a metal lathe these
were magical moments and yet I'd forgot
about them this this summer in
particular I'd be sent to I'd be sent
from the east coast to to California to
you know for no apparently reason that
other than it seemed like a good idea to
spend time with Grandpa
and and this summer he said I remember
him telling me that we were gonna build
an engine you know an internal
combustion engine and and I showed up
and he said the kid has arrived and
there's a box there I knew what you know
I knew what a kid looked like right
build model airplanes right there was
like lots of parts and instructions you
glue him together he opened up the box
and there were these four blocks of
metal in it and I was like where's the
engine and he says it's in there we have
to get it out and there's this blueprint
and and it was like you know it's like a
sculptor who sort of says you know you
take the block of marble and you cut
away the parts that aren't that aren't
the figure he
showed me how to cut away the parts of
metal that weren't the engine and you
know we spent this we spent the summer
you know with on the metal lay of these
kerlick uses of aluminum and and steel
building up around it was and it was
absent magical and yet somehow I forgot
about it for 35 years and the reason I
and as I said I flashed back after
having my Alibaba experience I flashback
it's like why I used to do that but
there's grandpa in his workshop how did
I forget and I realized that I he was an
inventor but he was not an entrepreneur
and I wanted to be an entrepreneur I
want to build a business and I had
because he was powerless to take his
idea into the world I sort of felt that
wasn't the right path that wasn't a that
that wasn't what I wanted it was the
full it was the complete cycle it was
the end-to-end control of an idea and
the realization in the marketplace is
what I wanted and grandpa never achieved
that and it didn't seem relevant in the
modern day this is a movie that came out
a few years ago it's called flash of
genius and it's about a similar
situation this is about the invention of
the intermittent windshield wiper which
is like the windshield wiper the pauses
you know stops and then goes when it's
not running very hard and it's it's a
real it's a cautionary tale of the 20th
century manufacturing world and what it
says is this guy invented the
intermittent windshield wiper but then
he didn't he then he patent it like my
grandfather did but what he then the
mistake he made is he didn't choose to
hand it off to Ford or GM although he
you certainly wanted a license of him
but he what he wanted to do was to be an
entrepreneur as well he wanted to to
make it and in those days you had to
build a factory so in 1961 he mortgaged
his house starts work on the factory 62
still working on the factory 63 still
bringing the assembly lines forklift
still working on the factory second
mortgage and cetera in 1964 as the movie
tells it the factories still not done
it's raining he leaves locks the door
turns the corner and he sees the new
1965 Mustangs turning the corner raining
and the windshield wipers pause and he
realized that his idea has been stolen
he's ruined he goes insane movie then
entertainingly follows his descent into
and to mad
but the lesson was don't try to make
stuff don't try to become in
manufacturing don't try to build your
own factory because that way lies
madness and that's and that was the
sobering lesson of the 20th century and
that's why we will gravitated toward
digital because the barriers to entry
were so much lower this is what the
factory looks like today this is tech
shop this is one of many so-called maker
spaces or hacker spaces that are
spreading around the world this one is
built on the gym model so when you when
you go to your gym and you become a
member of your gym what you're really
doing is you're you're basically having
access to machines that are too
expensive or bulky to have in your home
you have access to trainers who help you
use them and you have access to other
people who you know peers who are you
know inspire you by by working hard and
you know sort of yeah showing you know
being into the whole thing now apply the
same model to manufacturing when you
become a member of tech shop and there's
I think five in the United States but
but but hundreds of others like them
it's about a hundred dollars a month and
you have access to 3d printers to laser
cutters CNC machines to traditional
machines machining equipment to all the
software you would need to training
classes to coaches and shoot lots of
other people who are doing inspiring
things the the guy here in the front
right there is is doing a wireless
control modules for the smart grid
electric grid at the end of the process
at the end he's building sort of you
know a small batch right here at the end
he puts a little sticker abb on it and
the sticker actually is that these are
distributed by ABB the big Swedish
engineering conglomerate and so when you
buy these things from ABB for God knows
how much they you assume it's made in a
big Swedish factory but it's not it's
made in a tech shop and the guy behind
him is building a vapor deposition
chamber for synthetic diamonds and back
there that is a lunar lander because why
not this is what we do in these places
um so this right here is basically a
bunch of a bunch of inventors who are
working together on digital fabrication
tools to basically do the whole thing
to invent to prototype and then
ultimately to upload to the cloud or
whatever to to produce it whatever scale
they can make make a few they can make
many the the point is that they are
fully empowered to be manufacturers as
well as well as inventors and it's $100
a month this is a spread of just the
maker spaces you know around the world
there I visited three in the UK alone I
just heard like yesterday that the the
old silk mill which is the very first
Factory I think I'm not just repeating
what I was told yesterday I think it was
isn't Devon the very first Factory in
the UK is being turned into a makerspace
which is really pointless um
I in in in in the the book which came
out this week I makers my tell a story
of the Manchester Fab Lab which is again
being built in one of the original
factories in Manchester and there's this
there's a sort of poignant notion that
you know in the soda shell of the first
Industrial Revolution we're building you
know the new industrial revolution by
you know not by building huge machines
and working for the Machine but instead
by having by using these digital
machines and giving them to people for
you know as little as a hundred dollars
a month and you know if you know if your
your city is on this map it will be soon
you know this these things are cheap and
they're easy and the number of ideas
that are out there in the garages of the
world just waiting to be released is
countless justice just as the web
revealed in the digital space and it's
just now gotten to the point that it's
that that anybody can do it anywhere
this is this is how we're gonna fund it
this is Kickstarter I'm just a quick
show of hands how many people here have
heard of Kickstarter ok the next show of
hands how many Larry contributed to a
Kickstarter project good oh that's
fantastic this is a given that it's
actually yeah it hasn't even been open
to the UK I think yet although will be
soon that's that's terrific
so Kickstarter solves the other
necessary element which is the how do we
fund this stuff the answer is not
venture capital it's not banks it's
absolutely not government the answer is
its it's your customers and you know
what Kickstarter revealed we by the way
completely accidentally Kickstarter
intended to be kind of an arts and arts
site where you were gonna you know fun
opera and film but this turned out to be
a great site for startups manufacturing
startups um it turns out to solve like a
kind of a you know heads laughingly
obvious problem with a manufacturing
entrepreneurship or any kind of
entrepreneurship which is to say you get
the money at the wrong time so what when
you what happens is that is that you
know you you you you invent a project a
product you then prototype it you then
you know build the tooling you get the
inventory the component inventory you
build up the parts inventory it goes
into the distribution channel and
eventually gets them to the stores or
whatever and it's sold and then people
buy it and then you get the money back
like like months or years after you
needed it but you you meet of the money
at the beginning and you get the money
at the end what Kickstarter did and
those in many of you here use it you
know this they basically built it around
pre-orders and what happens is that you
set this this is the Pebble watch which
is the the most successful the
Kickstarter project although there are
many who've now passed a million dollars
what they do is they set this target
they sort of say if I can raise a
hundred if we if we these four guys in
Palo Alto who came up with a notion of
this cool watch can raise $100,000 we'll
make it and um three things happen first
of all you get the money you need to do
the prototyping upfront no venture
capital required second of all you've
done the market research if you don't
raise the money it probably wouldn't
have sold you've saved yourself time and
trouble and you know an indie risked the
the product and the third and this is
really magical is this up there the
comments in the backers there at the end
a so they're almost 70,000 people five
thousand comments that's that's a
community and what's powerful about this
community is that number one they have
bought into the product they're they
don't just want a product they want this
product to happen they bought into a
concept they bought into a part of the
people they bought into the idea they
become evangelists they become they
become invested in the idea number two
they have they have their own thoughts
about how to make it better so in the
days after this product was first
announced the comments came you know the
feedback became sort of sort of loud and
clear
it should be it wasn't waterproof
initially that should be waterproof so
they backers said I would hear you we'll
make it waterproof they had bluetooth
3.0 and it should have been Bluetooth
4.0 lower power consumption we got it
well ordered visible order the parts
they wanted new colors there's like okay
done and so now now not only are the
inventors getting the feedback from
their customers but now the customers
feel like they they partly own the
product and it's like there's a little
bit of me in that watch so not only do I
want it but I want other people to want
it I want to you know it's like a
selfish DMA right you want your idea to
spread and so these customers are pre
funding the product making it better and
then become the marketing engine and
they are there that's that's you know
that's that's seventy thousand in the
end people out there who are sort of you
know selling this product to other
people sort of saying I back and by the
way when you back at you you've started
your you're encouraged to tweet it and
sort of usually we've all seen this you
know I just backed Pebble watch on
Kickstarter and you're now but you've
now become a social marketing engine for
the product I mean you know you can't
buy this kind of publicity God knows you
know Sony who released their own
SmartWatch at the same time knows this
the Sony watch which is a perfectly good
product from a obviously a huge company
kind of you know fell flat why is the
Pebble watch from for kids in Palo Alto
is the sort of the hot SmartWatch that's
the power of crowdfunding that's the
power of building things the maker way
bottoms up entrepreneurial er start up
with you know democratizing the tools of
production so this is this is the big
news we've always had tankers we've
always had you know garages and
hobbyists and DIY etc but the big change
is that it starts digital it starts on
screen they very act of designing
something in a CAD program and this is
just in Sketchup which is one of many
the very act of designing something in a
CAD program then prototyping it in a
digital fabrication tool on your desktop
like a 3d printer means that you can
make mini as easily this the way it
works is is is this absolutely remember
remember when I showed you the first
slide that the laser the
the apple laserwriter um one of the
magical things about it is that it spoke
a language called postscript it's a page
description language and the thing about
PostScript is it's the same language
that the biggest printers in the world
speak so you could print look protect on
your own printer and then send that file
up to an industrial printer and have
millions made and have absolute
predictability of what it was going to
look like it was it was a common
language at every scale and so the first
time printing became scale free or scale
agnostic in other words it worked at the
small and at the large scale that's
really powerful
it means you would now have you can
harness you know the industrial tools
the same thing is happening with with
with with design the something called
g-code which is basically disk
PostScript and you know your smallest 3d
printer and the biggest you know robotic
factories in China all speak g-code so
it's simply a matter of uploading your
file to the cloud and it gets made if
you you can see it you can have a 3d
printer in your desktop where you can
send it to shapeways or pinoke oh and
they can make it in any substance you
can make it in plastics and in various
resins and glasses and metals you can
make it in titanium you know I I took a
little robots and set it up and had it
made in titanium it's not crazy cheap
but but you can make it in any material
you want and that's you know you know
any shows up ten days later um
that's magical where you can you can do
the same thing with laser cutting or
seam seeing or you know surfaces like
panocha will actually combine the parts
and dropship them to customers so really
if you've got a factory in the cloud you
just upload the file and and there you
go this is this is this is new so
remember what I was saying that you know
with desktop publishing we all became
publishers but we were kind of crappy at
it and we had to learn the language of
500 years of publishing we now have to
learn the language of design but doesn't
have to be as hard as it used to be one
of the things that I've really been
opening here in the UK is understanding
how deep making and and you know in an
industry and design is in the culture
design technology is still curriculum so
we you know in when in the United States
we used to when when I was kid kid we
had Industrial Arts and Home Economics
and was a shop class
cooking the various sorts and it got it
got wiped out right so Industrial Arts
was was basically as as it became as so
in 1970s it became clear that working in
a factory was no longer route to the
middle class it became a kind of place
where where only the sort of the least
the lowest aptitude people would go it
gaan did end job and so shop class was
sort of eliminated from the curriculum
aside from the small amount that small
fact of people cutting off their fingers
and there was liability and I think I
was like the last generation to shop
class and at that point all we were
making was bombs and shooting and
throwing stars it was but you know it
was it was it was not it was not your
career path and God got to help us
and then Home Economics which was
cooking was basically destroyed as part
of the as the notion that was
reinforcing gender stereotypes so I
think I waved political correctness and
I'm gonna do that so we wiped it out and
we instead we got - we got computer
class where we learned how to do
PowerPoint and yet okay you didn't you
kept it I was just visiting a school a
state school in Swindon where they have
this fantastic have a whole wing that's
designed technology and they have laser
cutters and they have 3d printers it's
it's it's it's in the DNA it's in the
air it's in the water I mean you know
the birthplace of the industrial first
Industrial Revolution still values
making stuff you know in a sense Britain
is the best position country in the
world to train a generation to become
designers to understand that design is
not is not artsy or only something you
need to get a degree in that design is
something we can all do and that's you
know the moment a kid design something
on a screen and that produces it and
takes it home they realize that anything
they can imagine they can make real and
you know God knows it's the web taught
us there's a lot of ideas out there it's
as simple as this so you know when your
word processor when you're finished
typing something out you go to the file
menu and you pick print and you go out
it comes on a manufacturing device
called a printer or in your photo
management software where you can also
pick print or you can upload the photo
to some service and have it printed as a
book or or you know greeting cards and
things like that
the cat programs all now have this
access to cloud cloud manufacturing so
they also rather than Prince they have
make and and what happens is you just
sort of junior design something in this
case the dollhouse and then you just
sort of pick a menu item and it says
would you like to send this to a service
to be made and you just kind of walk
through this wizard and it's kind of
coaxes you coaches you through materials
and costs and volumetric Ino calculation
it's also kind of calm basically you
know sort of phd's worth of
manufacturing have been turned into
software algorithms and you you know you
type in your credit cards and you know
ten days later it shows up this is what
this is what my kids do so we're a
little brutal when it comes to
technology my wife is is kind of
anti-technology ironically enough and uh
and so the children are only allowed two
hours of video game time per weekend day
and the girls are really into the sims
and we have we've got five kids and
three girls and the girls all love
building these kind of virtual doll
houses on the sims and they're really
cool and you can build furniture and
populate with people and quite a class
anything was actually designed as an
architecture game bye-bye
well right who did Sin City and the
others and what the questions was you
know how do you grade architecture and
the answer was the happiness of the
people in and in the building and so
they had to invent these people called
The Sims 2 essentially grade the
architecture I'm going end up is this is
awesome awesome dollhouse and bing the
timer like a little the windup the Hello
Kitty timer goes off and it's time for
them to stop the video home time and
they're like ah see come on kids play in
the real world and they're like play
with your real dollhouse and they're
like but it's not as cool as the one I
just made and I just designed this this
you know AHA there's at this house and
The Sims that's built on the kind of the
madman 1950's styling and daddy will you
buy me that kind of furniture for my
real dollhouse and you know I'm usually
pretty good at this and you know I have
a pretty good you know so the the root
to know is it's pretty quick when it
comes to the credit card but in this
case I thought I would do a little
research so I go on Amazon to find out
you know how dollhouse furniture is
available and the answer is not very
much it's crazy expensive and it's all
the wrong size know if any of you have
you know children with doll houses but
they all come in different
the people to get the furniture than the
right size as the people in the room is
super tricky and if you get it wrong the
kids are upset and I said but I said
okay I'm not gonna buy if the dollhouse
furniture from Amazon but we do have a
3d printer so we went on to Thingiverse
which is the repository of of things and
we googled around and we searched around
and they've got wonderful dollhouse
furniture designs and this was just
right exactly the right chair and then
we printed it and then they painted it
and they did that for all the rest of
the house and they have free dollhouse
furniture and my boys said that's pretty
cool but we're not into dollhouse
furniture so they made Warhammer 40k
figures and painted them and augmented
them with all sorts of all sorts of
awesome death-dealing accessories and if
you are a toy company this should give
you chills this is this is you know you
have just seen your mortality because
you know given a choice between the
exactly the Wrights toy designed by the
kids and made on the spot for free
versus buying something mass
manufactured out there from the store
they'll take this any time we basically
you know we have now created the ability
for them to take their ideas and make
them real and you know and this is our
crazy this is our crappy matrix style
you know 3d printer just imagined when
remember remember dot matrix ones the
binding em was really noisy with little
hammers that hit the ribbon isms black
and white and today we have ink jets
that have three colors and they're
beautiful photo resolution and that took
say 15 years to go from one to the other
maybe 20 it's not gonna take that long
with 3d printers is absolute no reason
why a 3d printer can't be mixing three
colors and producing any you know a
multicolored you know textured surfaces
in any substance for free or sent you
for free the consumables are just like
ink and you get it in more or less now
and it's just right for you so this is
this is the world that our children are
growing
and if they don't have it now they will
they will soon and this is that desktop
publishing moment this is the PC moment
this is the web moment when suddenly
people say I don't need a degree I don't
need permission I can just do it and you
know I if I'm gonna give you all one
homework assignment so if you have
children this this holiday season
consider getting a 3d printer remember
remember um I think I'm gonna guess at
our age here um you know average it out
over time but I mean I remember I
remember the like in the 1980s or maybe
you know this was like I guess the 80s
there was that moment when the personal
computer became sort of you know kind of
kind of affordable and then your parents
would buy it for you there's a buy a
home computer right it's for the home
was for the family it wasn't quite clear
wise clearly something to do with
education probably you know is sort of a
necessary skill for the 21st century I
guess you could program it
I'm etc but it was a big it was big
investments you know it's like $2,000 or
whatever and and he'd bring it in and
there it was and immediately kids
figured it out right they took it over
and the parents never touch it again and
you know and and and a generation of
entrepreneurs who builds you know the
Mark Zuckerberg the Bill Gates's the
world all came out of that moment you
know is the BBC micro or the Amstrad or
you know we've all been there and the
sense Raspberry Pi which some of you may
have heard of this is an effort to
regain that that moment well the 3d
printer I think is that so so if you can
I'll be about $2,000 if you if you have
children and you want to see that the
light bulb go off consider buying a 3d
printer this this this holiday bring it
home and see what happens and the one
thing I can tell you is that I can't I
can't tell you what the killer app of 3d
printers is yet for us is toys for you
maybe something else but I can tell you
that the generation that grows up with
this and you know takes and considers
this concept of whatever you can imagine
you can make is going to find that
killer app and it's going to amaze us
and maybe change the world
so these tools are free
this is Autodesk one two three D it's
another example of it again you know
rather than print there's there's
there's there's this make you just sort
of there's my crappy enclosure for my my
oh wait okay so it's kind of an amusing
side story I I thought that because my
grandfather had invented the automatic
sprinkler system I I asked myself well
what would he do today differently and I
say why he yeah he'd be an Arduino based
open source web connected automatic
sprinkler system and so I did that
although I don't even have a lawn which
is kind of ironic anyways this is an
enclosure to open sprinkler which is my
my my my Omar's to my grandfather and
then then you go over to to to make it
so yeah make it and and that walks you
through the you know the sort of how to
do it and then you know I ended up that
interestingly what I when I when I had
it fabricated shapeways and and then
delivered it turns out that my my walls
were way too thin so there's a little
lesson a cheap lesson little lesson all
the same this is and you don't even need
to download stuff for a Tinkercad on the
web is free and and really easy to use
very kid-friendly and in a sense kids
get this stuff if you played video games
you understand polygons and 3d
geometries if you played minecraft you
get this you know the sims you know the
lego Digital Designer our children
completely understand CAD they don't
know it's CAD they don't call it CAD but
they understand the idea of creating 3d
virtual spaces and and now the software
just kind of you know helps them do that
and then kokis them coaches them through
the process of making it real so you
know manufacturing has been turned into
a menu item that's you know that's what
democratization technology can do you
know the Apple slogan rip mix burn that
changed the music industry right you
know rip the music you know sort of you
know rip it off the the CD mix it you
know create your own variations of it
then burn it
and since manufacturing the sense burn
on your own CD distributed and then they
take it to the web or whatever you know
we democratized the act of creation of
music distribution and music marketing
of music it was you know incredibly
vibrant for what it did to the music
industry and they're not actually that
bad to the music industry itself despite
what the labels will tell you we now
have the manufacturing equivalent i if
you have an iPad I think probably
how many people have I pets terrific
okay second homework assignment when you
get home go to the iTunes Store and
download a free application called 1 2 3
D cash and what this is is this will
turn your iPad into a reality scanner
you're going to capture reality by
basically you basically walk around an
object or a person you go with your
camera you go click click click click
click click click look like you then
press a button it uploads all these
pictures into the cloud and then
produces a 3d polygon mesh and and once
you have the polygon mesh you can then
do a little cleanup or a lot of cleanup
and then you can print a PEZ dispenser
because why not so we've we've just done
it you don't even have to design stuff
yourself you can just capture reality
change it and print it out yourself you
don't like the handle on your coffee cup
scan it fix it print it out make your
own this is this is kind of amazing and
it's free
and it's in your iPad already by the way
I suggest you use natural light that's
just my uh we're still early days but
natural light take a lot of shots tried
a couple times and you will you will
have basically captured reality and you
can modify it and you can do you know
can do 3d printing you can just see him
saying you can print out layers on
cardboard there are many copies of my
head out there and cardboard if for some
reason autodesk decided to to use me as
their spoke said i I wish I'd known I
would have smiled anyway so so that's
kind of that's kind of cool 3d scanning
used to be really expensive and now it's
a free app and your iPad Oh an iPhone by
the way so I'm your iPhone as well so
that's pretty cool alright so let me
just finish with this one last point
what does how does this change you know
the nature of companies and industry and
the economy anima tells started to serve
two guys and the guy on your left is
Ronald Coase in the 1930s you know at
the sort of you know this industry whose
broham is booming I'm Ronald Coase too
as a University of Chicago economists
asked a kind of fundamental question
which is why do companies exist you know
any it's kind of
mysterious you know you know why do we
work under one roof you know for the man
you know why do we do that why don't we
just you know work individually this you
know kind of you know agents individual
agents enough in a gig economy and he
came with a theory of transaction costs
it we we worked for company to minimize
transaction cost and what he means is
it's basically the complexities the
communication costs of getting things
done
so the reason we worked for a company
under one roof with the collective
mission is that you know who does what
she does accounts receivable and she
does accounts payable and you know when
you want something done you know who to
ask and those things those sort of you
know you know clear roles and
responsibilities some lines of
communication in our transaction cost
and and the reason we work under one
roof is to simply make it clear who does
what that's great
works perfectly well that's why you know
all of us are employed and that's and
that's and that's obviously the key to
the 20th century the guy on the right is
Bill joy one of the cofounders of Sun
Microsystems and you know he too worked
for a company but he had a little uh
quibble he said whoever you are the
smartest people in the world don't work
for you which is kind of unfortunately
true now you know by the way
statistically of course is true right
you know that for any given job the
smartest person in the world is probably
you know China or India or whatever I
mean they mystically there's no possible
way they're the person you happen to be
working with in the next cubicle is the
right person in the best person in the
world for that particular job by the way
if you think this through that's also
true for your spouse and it's best not
to think about this it'll drive you
absolutely not love the one you're with
and there you have it it's it's the joy
paradox now why do we settle for you
know the people who work with us because
it's really hard to find the best person
in the world we end up with we end up
finding the easiest person in the world
so we end up with with all these talents
filters we go with you know did they
have the right degree do they have the
right CV the right at work experience do
they live in the right country they
speak the right language are they you
know they are they available do they not
have a criminal record you know all that
kind of stuff and that's how it went
that and we once they pass although tell
all those tests then we sort of hire
them so we sort of minimize the risk but
we haven't we haven't ena maximized the
potential what are you gonna do right I
mean that's you know how you know I know
the best person in the world and you
know for this particular job lives in
China but I don't speak Chinese etc and
so that was the sort of the the sort of
tragedy of the the Koshien model is that
it ended up with a suboptimal solution
this is the cover of make magazine the
maker movement was I was named by a guy
named Dale Dougherty who runs Riley's to
be publishing company to have a division
and it's now called the make division
make magazine to sort of the Bible
that's of that of the movement and they
have Maker Faire and there's something
like 50 of them around the world the New
York Maker Faire is gonna be next next
next week and my hundred thousand people
go to these Maker Faires they are just
like you can't go the garages of the
region to open up and all these ideas
come out and is wonderful um last year
on the cover they decided to focus on
drones and I told you about my little
sort of adventure into Arduino and
making things and anyway and start with
blimps and then it kind of went horribly
wrong and I I now run a company that
makes more drones than the US military
and they're open source so that'll end
well and and they decide to focus on on
on on drones and you know the whole
notion of you know that bottoms-up
aerial robotics and all that and and
they and they took this picture of my
co-founder of our website called DIY
drones and the companies call 3d
robotics and and this is and and this
guy's name is Jordi munos I just want to
end with a little
about Geordi because I think this sort
of speaks to the joy paradox when I
started my my explorations of what's the
maker model could do and and you know
what bottoms up manufacturing and
Arduino and all its kind of stuff and I
started with something it seemed
uninteresting to me which was that you
know I knew robotics was you know things
that moved ground on tables in the
ground and that's come done and I didn't
feel like I had much to add but like the
air was harder and I actually played
around with robotics with the kids and
that was a disaster because kids are
really hard to impress when it comes to
robotics we did Lego Mindstorms expen
all day and it like bounces off the wall
moves backwards and they're like lasers
you know transformers come on three
stories high come on dad Holly was
really ruined robotics for children and
then we flew playing I flew into a tree
and and I couldn't you know that was
humiliating but was more humiliating
when I climbed into the tree to recover
it and it was all bad and I said well
maybe a robot could fly the plane better
than me so I started a site this site
DIY drones which is basically a kind of
a very web like notion to sort of share
your ignorance and this journey
discovery I know nothing about about
drones and their robotics but I thought
I would just sort of look around and if
I found something interesting I'd posted
on the site and then other people you
know started helping and finding their
own interesting things and then this guy
posted a video of him flying a
helicopter with a Wii controller he'd
kind of hacked a Wii controller and a
helicopter and then putting our dueña
board and there was like whoa that's
awesome and then he'd post a couple more
videos and I got in touch with him his
name was Jordi and and we start doing
some projects together and we were
posting all the design files and
everyone is this is the moment when
people said could you please make it for
me and I said Jordi you know if we're
gonna make stuff for people were
probably going to start a company sir
said cool and I said so tell me a little
something about yourself they never met
him Geordi turned out to be 19 years old
he is from Tijuana just graduate from
high school and not been to college he
was actually just moved to a suburb of
Los Angeles waiting for his green card
and we decided to start a company
together and it's
started has been his bedroom then it
went to his kitchen then it went to a
little garage he rented and there's this
Geordi with GGO and today he is the CEO
of a multimillion-dollar aerial robotics
company with massive factories in San
Diego and and Mexico and he's 26
he still hasn't been to college and he I
think is the answer to Joy's paradox ten
years ago when the editor of Wired was
going to start a drone company what are
the odds that he would end up with a 19
year old Mexican high school graduate
and yet he was the best person in the
world for this job he didn't have the
right degree he didn't speak the right
language he didn't spike you should come
to the right country even come the right
country he didn't have the resume he
didn't have any of that but what he did
have was intelligence energy ideas and
access to the greatest information
resource the world has ever seen which
does the internet and more to the point
I didn't find him he found me so the
answer to Joy's paradox is that is that
you can't find the smartest people in
the world all you can do is share your
ideas work in public create communities
and then they'll find you and today we
have 30,000 members in the community we
have more than 100 developers by day
they work from Google and Apple and IBM
and Microsoft and are highly paid and by
night they work for us for free and
they're driven by their passions and
they feel like they're building
something that matters and they feel
this Avoyelles he to the community we
never could have found them we never
could have even if we'd found them we
couldn't have hired them they won't work
for us for money but they will work for
something that they believe in for the
other members of the community so we've
solved it we've solved Joy's paradox
what we've discovered is the web's
innovation model is the answer you don't
have to work for a company what you have
to do is work for a movement work for a
community you have to work in public and
share your ideas and we we open-source
them there's lots of other ways
Kickstarter is another way but the point
is when you attach the web's innovation
model to these new digital manufacturing
tools
cooing our pick-and-place machines that
we bought initially on eBay then you
gets what amounts to a new Industrial
Revolution modeled after the web not
with a concentrated power of the old
Industrial Revolution but with the
democratized power of the digital age so
in a sense it boils down to this that
just a saw as hardware as the new
software atoms are the new bits that
everything we've seen over the last 20
years was just the prelude to what could
ultimately be an even bigger
transformation when we take it to the
physical world to manufacturing to
making real things to the economy all
around us thank you very much
thank you thank you so I think we have a
little time here we have microphones
there's some standing mics in the back
and in the balconies and and mobile mics
down here there's some hands up already
I'm the the woman on the aisle their
Kickstarter yes how can you when you put
your image up on the screen how do you
protect that design if it's good follow
yeah so a great question and there's two
things first of all what you share on
Kickstarter is the idea now you can
decide to share everything about it's
including design files so you can just
share the idea um we actually were part
of the open hardware movement which is
to say we don't just give away our ideas
we give away everything we give away all
the design files and we're licensed so
that people can actually take our files
and and cassell against us now so we
we're kind of the radical left of this
moment in this movement we believe it's
not that we don't believe in
intellectual property because in a sense
we license these things under under
under a license protects intellectual
property but everybody gives the right
for other people to use it and to sell
against us because we we think that the
social advantages of sharing outweigh
any kind of competitive or economic
disadvantages we'll have in piracy now
so we think we give away a little will
get back more in return which is to say
people will take the ideas and they'll
prove upon them and because the license
requires those improvements or so-called
derivative designs to also be open that
we all will be able to collectively kind
of ratchet up and and innovate faster
than anyone could ourselves truth is we
are ripped off on massive scale by the
time we put up with post our files and
ten days later the Chinese clone us and
pirate our stuff and they violate our
trademark and they ignore our license
and they and their and they just they
just rip us off and it dries me but zerk
and yet I still do it and that's because
for every 99 who ripped us off one's
going to improve the product and and
then that design comes back to us and
then we can build on their design I just
want a one little story about about
about piracy and about ripping and I'll
come back with your Kickstarter at the
end so the you know
it againand drives me crazy when we
spend like like months of developing a
design and you know tens of thousands of
dollars we put it out there and the
Chinese clone just like that but one in
one case in particular and usually
they're super sloppy about it I mean
they repeat our errors and there's no
documentation and they copy our
marketing materials but in one case they
actually translate our manual to Chinese
I thought that was just interesting
enough that I would find out who this
person was you know this guy his name
was hazy oh that says username and I got
in touched I said look I like if the why
did you translate her manual to Chinese
you know I would like you know one point
however a million billion people a
billion people to two years our product
but would you mind doing it on our site
because it turns out we are manual
changes all the time and we'd like you
to share the same image files so that
way as we change and we don't want them
to be out of date so you can share the
image files in you trust in Chinese and
he said first of all hi thank you for
you know being nice about this sure I'd
be happy to and he just said he'll need
a login into our wiki and so I gave him
a login into the wiki and I was fine but
I forgot we weren't really sophisticated
back in those days um turns out that
login to the wiki was also the login to
the version control system that was our
source code so the first thing he did is
he ported his manual over and translated
Chinese and did a really good job of it
and the second thing he did was we
perfectly Naturals that he changed the
the user interface to the code so that
it was also so the menus were in Chinese
which makes perfect sense I was like oh
I don't thought about that but sure okay
I got that and then he started fixing
bugs in the software and today hey Z's
one of our top contributors and he's
giving back and in a sense our pirates
work for us
now because we didn't treat them like
criminals and we invited them in now
he's one and they're still 99 people who
completely rip us off but that one
moment of recognizing that open source
can actually work and if you treat
people like they're part of a community
and you make them and you still wake
them up to the notion that actually
giving back has some advantages and
they're collectively it it's a little
counterintuitive I totally grant you I
mean we're always like oh my god and
give away your intellectual property you
give away your ideas of what you know
and it doesn't feel right when you get
ripped off but over time it pays off so
I've got years of doing this right now
I can tell you that it that on balance
it's a hue tisn't it positive we have 20
years of open source and software
showing us that it works so back to
kickstarter by and large ideas are done
dozen ideas III don't want mine I want
to ruin ruin anyone's you know sir and I
heared but I think ideas are essentially
worthless
I think execution is everything
everybody's got an idea but until they
make it until they make it real and show
they had a competence to you know to to
you know write the code and manufacture
and all that kind of stuff basically I
don't take him seriously that's why no
one in our community everyone's got
ideas no one pays any attention then
they post a YouTube video of the demo
and it's like now I'm paying attention
you have proven that your ideas is
plausible you sort of passed this sort
of you know the reality check any proven
you're competent enough to to execute
now I'm gonna follow you so I think in
on the Kickstarter world people give
away the ideas because no one's gonna
beat them to market they can execute
faster you know they they they basically
have the community behind them you can
steal the idea but you can't steal a
community so it's a little it's a little
sort of you know makes your stomach a
little flip a few times when you do it
but we've got 20 years of experience
saying that it works thank you
yes over here um it's fascinating what
you said what about the implications of
all of this which industries if we wind
forward 10 15 20 years they're really
gonna find themselves challenged or new
ones open up you know and you know it's
great answer I'd like I don't have a
great answer for you I can say that you
know again using the historical
precedent my first book the longtail was
about sort of how the the niche the
little you know the ability for for the
you know individuals and small companies
and entrepreneurs etc to make you know
products for for the discriminating for
the you know for the minority taste
rather than just the mass market was
change the culture and everyone thought
it was going to be the end of the
blockbuster and everyone was like you
know haha Hollywood still around you
know television studio I'll still didn't
find clearly long tail you know didn't
work you know obviously it was a
misunderstanding
what what it was is not the end of the
blockbuster up at the end of the
monopoly of the blockbuster and today
every one of us lives partly in the
world of mains
dream media and and and you know
Hollywood and television all this and in
the world of the niche we all have some
some passion or or thing we're into that
sort of in a sense defines us more as an
individual so you know yes we're
mainstream in some part of our life and
were and we're super minority taste and
unique another part of our life and and
the to co-exist really well so it wasn't
that you know that the the Hollywood
lost its that the niche one there's a
place there's a place for minority to
eat taste I think the same thing is
gonna happen in in manufacturing I'm
you've already seen it right so with an
art with food you know the rise of
artisanal food and locally grown foods
and you know if you look at Etsy and
sort of the rise of you know you know
the artisanal handcrafted nature um my
daughter and I were my daughter I'm
asked for a a jewelry tree and I was
quite sure what jewelry but it's a
little sort of thing to hang jewelry on
and and you know turn that you can go to
Crate and Barrel which is like a big big
retailer and you can buy kind of a
generic jewelry or you can go to Etsy
and buy something really unique and cool
she one one had pandas involved and so
of course we went to that one because
because she doesn't want to but have the
same jewelry tree everybody else says
she wants um that sort of speaks to her
individual skills and that's now
available and Etsy is a billion-dollar
business you know as a marketplace for
the hand crafting so I think I think
we've seen the rise of the artisanal
we've seen the sort of the value of the
DIY we've seen the value of the longtail
and the unique etc so does this mean
that's mass manufacturing is over
absolutely not you know you're still
gonna buy your spoons you know produce
to bend the millions but when you look
at these other parts of your life you
know I mean you know it you know when
you look at the your Smart Watch do you
want to buy a Smart Watch from Sony or
do you want to buy a Smart Watch from
you know four brilliant kids in Palo
Alto I mean increasingly the quality is
the same the price is the same one of
them seems to be innovating at a super
fast pace and the other seems to be kind
of stuck in the you know mass
manufacturing model and we're
gravitating towards towards towards the
towards the niche just as we did with
digital stuff next I think I'm gonna let
the microphone guide me I see a hand up
over here and let's take what move over
to let's actually let me be I mean let
me
democratize the microphone and let's
take one up here
is that is there standing my cars that I
move on like there's a standing mic to
the right okay would you mind would
somebody mind in the upper balcony go to
the mic and I'll come back to you with
the next question and now I'll take one
over here I think there's a hand unde
undecided the gentleman in the in the
jacket at the top of that of the aisle
and then I'll come back to you over
there
hi there just a quick question that to
be honest I I think you know I believe
in that this technology will
revolutionize the way things are made
but I'm fairly ignorant in terms of you
know just my knowledge of the field can
you recommend any resources that I can
you know that I could just use to really
get up to speed on on the technology
itself and then potential applications
and so on sure thank you that's a great
question you know obviously I miss if I
didn't mention there was a new book
makers the new Industrial Revolution
available outside that will be signing
after this speech there's also the Wired
magazine in the UK in the u.s. both have
but I you know uh broadly there's a
series of technologies and the minute
there's the 3d printers and the CNCs and
the laser cutters etc to be honest you
don't really have to kind of just study
them it's you know you can if you want
but it's kind of one of those you you
get one you sort of figure it out I
would actually if I was gonna start with
one thing first of all if you have an
iPhone or an iPad do get do get one to
3d catch and just play around with it a
little bit um go to if you want play
around with the the CAD tools go to
Tinkercad comm Tinkercad spelled just
like it sounds I mean just play around
with it a little bit and you might as I
say make magazines sort of the Bible
this and you can they have mixing you
can just subscribe just follow that feed
and they'll be kind of a make all maker
all the time but yeah it's it's a it's a
great learning moment but I would
recommend doing not just not just
reading get get something and start
playing around with it yes sir up there
Thanks yeah this technology is
incredible excites
for the professionals and the
enthusiasts but it just makes me think
about an old example of mass
customization like Nike ID yeah so as
far as I know it loses money and it's
funded basically as and marketing X yes
and I've my experience of it is that you
know it's quite a lot more expensive for
the trainers you wait right week ten
days for it to turn up it turns up and
you realize you're not the designer you
thought you were and you could probably
got much better stuff off the shelf this
is such an amazing variety on the shelf
so how do you answer that about what I
guess when you talk about some
observation are you talking for just
that not 0.5% of enthusiasts or do you
think there's a potential to go wider
than that yeah it's a great question III
do I do talk about that in the book I
mean mass customization I totally agree
has been largely a disappointment even
Dell doesn't really mess customize
anymore is this kind of canonical
example of mass customization and now
and now it you know turns out you just
don't really care what's inside your
computer I the problem with that mass
customization models that you basically
you're just changing the color on that
on a standard product right you know so
you know depend by the way B you know
that the first example is sort of the
democratize chosen production would
really t-shirts and coffee mugs right
these were standard standard innovation
platforms which is to say you know I
have to make the t-shirt but you can
design just a Threadless and and other
and other firms that allows you to kind
of design against a standard platform
and distracted all the manufacturing
stuff so that actually became more
successful people really could express
their creativity on t-shirts in the
coffee mugs but I agree is it it's a
little trivial what's different in all
of those is that those are really
limited which is to say here's a box and
you can start paint paint within the
lines um what we're talking about here
is unbounded anything you can imagine
you can make you're not you're not just
you know put a new logo on a Nike
sneaker you can invent an entire
industry and and that I think taps into
a deeper level of creativity and you
know again what's the killer app I mean
in our house is toys that's certainly a
lot more interesting the Nike ID I I
think you know no one else no one is you
know you know
you can the Disney's of the world will
let you put different different faces on
their princess you know put your own
face on their princess dolls but you
know they won't let you make up more
hammer 40k MEK and that's and that's
where I think again taps into a much
more interesting sort of you know
undaunted creativity the same way that
what was fascinating about the web
wasn't that you could fill out a
template but that you had a blank sheet
and yeah that's how creativity happens
and for the first time I think we have a
blank a blank page with with with
manufacturing where we can just do
anything so that's well you know what
we'll see but that's but I think it's a
good point and this is definitely goes
beyond what we've seen in you know Matt
customization of standard standard
products I think over over on this side
I will take one here and then we'll come
to the middle yeah how do you see the
ablution of the android apple OS and the
Samsung liable issue that evolved in
California last month question is do you
see an open source community eventually
evolving and displacing apple OS OS that
oh it's being a closed shop and you know
anyone that wants to approach has to pay
it's it's it's fees yeah how do you see
that evolving especially when you know
Dell sales are going on way down and
smartphones are going into basically the
smartphones of replacing pcs how do you
see that evolve in the next few years
yeah so I mean I'll bring that back to
the subject because they get the broader
open versus closed so you know in full
disclosure I
an Android user myself and Android is
now the leading the leading operating
system in mobile but not in tablets I
think it's largely cyclical which is to
say in times of rapid change and
complexity you kind of want the
vertically integrated you know Apple
model where you know one company makes
it easier and we're starting to see a
lot of the open-source hardware
including the next generation of 3d
printers go from the kind of hey you can
screw it together and later cut plywood
you know you can set all the PID
settings yourself and customize and do
anything you want which is a nightmare
and you know I've been through every
generation that MakerBot and I've got
the scars to show for it to this sort of
like I just want something that works
out of the box so we're kind of moving
towards the Apple model and you know the
next generation the ones the ones that I
recommend you buy you know be it's the
the new MakerBot or the the 3d systems
cube etc they're basically just closed
systems which I feel awfully feel sad
about but as a father and a user I'm
like yeah if it just make it work so
we're going through the Apple mode but
then as it gets more mature so that's
vertically integrated then as it gets
more mature and it's like okay get it
use case established it works etc I'd
like a little more innovation then it
tends to switch the horizontally
integrated which is where you have the
Android model so I think what happened
is that Apple was necessary to get us to
understand touchscreen smartphones but
it's like okay got it love it I'd like a
little more choice then there was an
opportunity for the open source model to
kind of kick back in and bring in more
more platforms more participation more
variety more more freedom so I think
it's kind of you know complexity leads
to control control sort of establishes
the market and then you kind of want
more complexity again because complexity
is choice over here thank you thank you
for your presentation I'm wondering in a
world where we've got diminishing
resource limited space increasing
population the technology we're talking
about could be part the solution but
could also be popped a problem yeah many
more plastic yeah what's your thoughts
in that well you know I mean I think
it's a great question and and I would
say them here's a couple things
just say first of all yeah yeah
absolutely we're making more plastic you
know it doesn't have to be plastic but
it is at the moment or make it locally
he knows so there's no waste nose no no
transportation from you know across the
across the Atlantic I know no
distribution and efficiencies second or
probably making less of it you know my
children value the things they make more
than the things they buy they value
there's actually quite a lot of research
and I talked about this in the book
there's quite a lot of research it's
call the IKEA effect where you build
something yourself you actually tend to
value it more there's a little bit of
you in it and even though you know all
you did it was screw it together you
sort of feel a sense of pride you know
unless you did it wrong in which case
you can feel a sense of shame but that
but the notion that you buy less but you
value it more or to say or the point you
make your own I mean look at the
difference between a home-cooked meal
and a purchase meal I mean there's a
reason why we we cook our own meals and
it's not that we have we can rival
McDonald's in terms of economies of
scale it's that we actually prefer we
value but there's more where there's
there's you know the act of making and
the quality of what we make over will
overcomes the economic in efficiencies
of a DIY and so I think that you know if
we get this right we become more local
boars in a sense we localize production
and although we don't have the same you
know McKean mechanical and economic
efficiencies the proximity compensates
for that and you know we don't have the
same sort of carbon carbon you know
consequences or the same waste or the
same sort of disposable relationship
with our stuff instead it's we made it
and we love it and we keep it and we
don't throw it out do we have time for a
matter of waiting Thomas oh yeah oh
there thank you hi my name is Nika
McDonald I was one of the pioneers of
DTP as we call it in the UK so I
remember your examples I could ask -
what problem is this the solution and
you've implicitly describe that to us
I'm not sure you've explicitly described
it but you also started talking about
the way in which the industrial
evolution had a profound
social effect and was transformative and
that was when it started is a moot point
but during the periods before that we
overthrew feudalism we urbanized people
we created new classes we created new
financial systems we change religions
the ones that were a bit kind of
friendlier to use eatery and that kind
of thing
and that was pretty profound and I
wonder when you took use the term
revolution how far going you really
think this is will it scale you know
we've I'm involved in a manifesto called
big potatoes and we've discussed a lot
these revolutions and very quickly get
to the limits of what you can print out
on a 3d printer now 1984 laser printers
were pretty limited too and now you have
irises and all these kind of things but
you can't integrate electronics into it
very easily you know you can't do well
you can do jumbo jet parts I guess but
not if you're Kris Anderson
you know actually isn't this just gonna
touch a very small part of our lives and
be a bit transit tree and not really
feel like a revolution at the end of the
day it was nice then but didn't really
make much impact I mean a fair point and
I would ask you know as one of the
founders of desktop publishing do you
think that you had an impact in the
world not just in terms of the the act
of publishing but in terms of what what
was published the voices and the ideas
and the creativity that was unleashed
well actually to your point and we've
discussed the long tail back in the day
and I think one of the interest things
about that is it Unleashed the past all
rights the AV archived IP that's you
know music labels have and so on but in
digital there are very few areas you can
really say that we've actually created
new media forms through digital you
could say that in games we have sure to
an extent in apps and so on but that's
really cd-roms reinvented and yet to be
right proven so actually I don't really
see a manifest future in this area so I
would I would you're making a
distinction between media forms and I
would I would actually focus rather on
the content I'm more interested in the
form in the media and then what we say
in it what it Unleashed was you know was
New Voices
new I point is not that we're making the
you know newspapers more newspapers and
you know and and and you know
different subjects the point is we're
not making newspapers remember you know
that the the Facebook's and the
Twitter's and the in the blogs of the
world are speaking you know about things
that matter to individuals not
necessarily to you know the industrial
scale of media as Cass Sunstein who
you'll know better from yeah
co-authoring nudge is observed you've
created echo chambers where people who
can have one view you can find people
with the same view okay what I mean is a
great global debate which is open minded
should we say so I would I would argue
and again again I can I'm simply making
assertion I know how to measure I would
argue the web has rich into our culture
that we have become more diverse there
has been room for the individual voice
there's been room for uniqueness I'm not
saying that you know that we all
necessarily live in the longtail but the
longtail is rich it has enriched all of
our lives by just giving us more choice
and allowing these voices to coexist on
the same on the same platform as as
there's the sort of you know mass voices
of the mainstream media so so I would
argue that if we believe if you would if
you would agree that the web has
enriched our culture then I would
stipulate that that that you know
implying democratized technology to
manufacturing won't rich the culture of
stuff as well that will have there will
be new things created new choices
available to us I don't know what
they're going to be I can't tell you
that they will be radically new new life
forms but I can tell you that that you
know you're not gonna be stuck with this
only the stuff that's made from China
you will have a choice and I'm presuming
that if they come from you know orders
magnitude more people and they will be
ordering order of magnitude more
creative diverse yes a last question
with microphone spending all your ideas
forward I was just wondering if you're
moving to a world where barcia becomes
more important than money where what
becomes brighter
Parcher ideas skills creation fortune
I've cued up my last book I have a whole
nother speech um yeah so so that's that
was the subject of my last book I'm free
which was very much the notion that the
rise of the non-monetary economy that
you know I mentioned that that in our
community are engineers who work on our
robotics you know
work for us for free which we could
never get them to do for money we could
pay them they won't take the money it's
trivial compared to their salary it's
kind of you know they kind of you know
you know they they're like you know if
you were to pay me for my work you'd
have to charge more for the product
which would mean that the price would be
higher which means it would be a doc buy
food people which undoes the entire
reason why I did this in the first place
so it's actually kind of becomes an anti
monetary in some sense that the social
the social motivations incentives for
their participation are so much greater
now obviously at the end of the day they
have to pay the rent and buy the food
and if they didn't have a day job they
wouldn't be able to do this night job
but the reality is is that you know we
all have passions that aren't tapped by
our day job you know the applications to
go with our vocations and you know what
the web taught us is that there's a
place for that energy that those spare
cycles can be harnessed to create
extraordinary things and we tend to do
it for free so you know not that
everything should be for free or that
everything will be for free but that we
now have a engine that does what money
does but on but driven by social
incentives himself instead now barter is
actually not the right word I don't
think that there's this barter implies a
sort of implicit compact which is that
sir I will do this if you do that I'm
instead what you have is this sort of
open-ended open-ended giving away stuff
on the hope that more will come back and
return you know you write you write your
ideas down and see what happens it's not
altruism by and large it's usually
enlightened self-interest which is to
say you want it you want says you want
to see something happen it's the web and
so we tend to do it in public you sort
of you know you invent something and you
then post it on Thingiverse because you
kind of want people to notice it and you
want recognition and then people like oh
that's completely awesome did you think
about adding this and you know someone
else's would you think about adding that
and now you've got a community and then
collectively you're innovating something
and there was no agreement beforehand
that they would get something in return
and yet then you know they started the
core philosophy this sort of the social
compact of the web is give stuff away
and see what happens
it's tends to work out for the best
thank you very much